Android Q beta three is here this
version has several new updates
including dark theme and gesture
navigation let's dive in beta three adds
a system setting to switch apps on a
device to use a dark theme having a dark
theme isn't just aesthetic on some
devices it can extend battery life
therefore when users switch to battery
saver mode the dark theme will
automatically be used on pixel and
selected om devices to customize your
app start theme extend your app theme
from theme dot app compat day/night or
material components from there you
enable the feature by calling app compat
delegate dot set default night mode the
recommended values for this are light
night no dark night yes use system
default night fellow system keep in mind
that the past in value is not persisted
so you need to set it each time your app
becomes visible you will also need to
update your themes styles and layouts so
that users can seamlessly switch between
your apps light and dark themes using
material design components makes this
especially easy because its color theme
system provides easy access to well
defined colors Android Q also introduces
gestural navigation allowing you to
perform sliding motions to both navigate
back one screen and return to the home
screen gestural navigation provides a
system-wide edge-to-edge experience this
means your apps can use more of the
devices screen on beta 3 a swipe up
shows the home screen and a horizontal
edge swipe will now take you back to the
previous app if your app relies on
similar gestures users may accidentally
trigger the system gestures and alter
the intended experience of your app for
example a horizontal edge swipe by
default takes you back to the previous
app if you encountered this sort of
conflict youth gesture exclusion
rectangles to override system gestures
within particular areas along device
edges when users perform a gesture
inside of these rectangles the gesture
will trigger an action in your app
instead of the typical system action
although gesture exclusion rectangles
give you flexibility in updating your
apps experience you should keep the
following best practices in mind
avoid vertical swipes near the system
navigation elements because this gesture
will always be a way for users to exit
the app we also don't recommend creating
a gesture exclusion zone that covers the
entire edge of the screen which the
system recognizes as a back action to
enhance user privacy Android has created
a sandbox view of external storage that
app start getting Android cue used by
default your app can access the files
that it creates on external storage but
access to other apps files through
runtime permissions is limited to common
media types such as photos and music to
access other files your app can request
that the user give permission to access
a particular file or directory by using
either the action open document or
action open document tree intent to help
you respond to your contacts questions
more efficiently and RQ introduces smart
actions
smart actions can now automatically
suggest actions and responses to
conversations for example in this
notification the system suggests replies
to the message and since the message
contains an address it includes a button
to navigate to that address the system
provides several suggestions for you so
you don't need to implement this
functionality from scratch in your app
you can analyze a list of messages to
see if there are any actions associated
with it using the suggests conversation
actions API path and conversation text
and the API will provide a list of
suggestions corresponding to possible
actions it will also generate a list of
possible replies but for now this reply
feature is only supported in English
we've also added an ability to detect
languages and a piece of text developers
can use the detect language feature of
the text classifier class to pass in
text and see what language it is in
enough of me talking go try it for
yourself follow the link in the
description to install Android cue beta
which is now available on more than 15
devices release notes and support
resources can be found on the Android Q
beta developer site let us know how you
like android cue by leaving us feedback
your feedback is important to us in
building a platform for everyone happy
coding
[Music]